je vais vous aider vous toucher non
j'avais juste kaboul un fermier tu
m'excuses romeria les larmes et j'en ai
pris que cinq pour venir à bout ce sera
ok bah je découvrais les quatre autres
des dans cette issue c'est à dire ils
ont retiré cette voie de poignet c'était
une belle surprise
ouais ok le 1 le monde doit se mettre
d'accord sur mer et voilà regardez on
dirait que je me suis fait agresser quoi
c'est de ma faute peut-être écho assez
de la mienne peut-être que je fasse
pareil en bas pour vous c'est fini ça
suffit qu'ils avaient réglé je vous fais
un sorte enfin tout le monde adore les
charges
arrêtez de gigoter faites bien attention
et hop ça fait drôle enfin pisa éviter
de toucher cette zone la vraie bas vous
vous plongez pas de vous d'aller
m'inspire la malade dans les ca suffit
mais arrêtez de tirer sur moi pantalon
comme ça tu sais quoi
c'est quoi c'est très bien quoi ça c'est
quoi arrêter tout j'ai pas touché pas
c'est une gaine ça sert à faire en sorte
que rien ne bouge pourquoi et des trucs
qui peuvent tomber de vos sous-vêtements
ou quoi